this one is absolutely wild you may have
seen or heard of this young lady we've
talked about her a couple times on the
show Riley Gaines she is a superstar
swimmer who has been outspoken against
males biological males swimming against
women and beating women right now we all
know that that is a legitimate argument
and feminists of 20 years ago would be
disgusted to know that a guy with a dick
is beating girls in swimming and the
feminists of today are applauding it
well Riley Gaines went to San Francisco
State University a couple days ago and
all she talked about was rights of women
keeping men out of women's sports things
of that nature she's the most lovely
Pleasant girl you could possibly imagine
and she is an extraordinary swimmer an
extraordinary swimmer she was assaulted
by a completely violent crazed lgbtq
plus double Spirit wing wang group and
assaulted by a trans activist I think
it's a guy as a girl or just watch the
video I mean this is crazy
I'm good
I'm coming I'm good I'm good trust me
okay all right
friends rights are human rights if you
mean by that your ability as an adult to
live with the same rights as everyone
else and dress as you wish and whatever
I agree with you if you mean trans
rights or human rights we get to chase
you down a hallway and assault you and
had the cops not been there rip you to
shreds and then I would slightly
disagree with that these people are
completely out of control there is not
one Democrat I could not find one not
one Democrat who was willing to condemn
that all right some Republicans did of
course imagine if that was flipped and
you had a bunch of let's say right-wing
activists chasing down you know a black
female we would be having you know riots
all over the country right now CNN would
be telling you this is white supremacy
blah blah blah you all get the double
standards okay that's just fine
um but but these people are out of
control and do you see how these things
are connected these the bad ideas
the bad ideas coupled with algorithms
coupled with a generation that is on
drugs both illegal and prescription
drugs has led to a bunch of crazy people
running down a hallway screaming at a
girl who's just saying all she's saying
is I as a girl would like to compete
against girls when it comes to swimming
[Music]